hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of our readers al-rahim who
asked me am I too old to start a
business so he said it's 53 years old he
wants to start a business in the fitness
industry and he's worried that he's too
old and wanted me to be brutally honest
with him to say if he's too old or not
the sort of business so I raheem you're
not too old to start of business just
like some people are too young and
started business you're never too old to
start a business as long as it's really
something that you're passionate about
and you feel like you're not a lot of
value to and I wanted to share two quick
stories hopefully will help give you
some guidance some motivation to want to
start your business the first is a man
named Ray Kroc who's 52 years old he had
his gallbladder removed he had arthritis
he had diabetes and he started a company
called McDonald's 52 years old and he
was convinced that the best days are
still ahead of him even though he had
all these melons now if you're in the
personal fitness industry I'm sure
you're going to be in much better health
than Ray Kroc was and he was 52 so you
only got one year older than the Ray
Kroc the second one is Harland Sanders
and he started a company called Kentucky
Fried Chicken KFC and he was 66 he was
bankrupt and 66 and that's when he
started up KFC and again was able to
turn it into a huge a successful company
so don't let H be a negative factor for
you a lot of things ahold entrepreneurs
back from starting a business or from
growing their business are these
negative limiting personal beliefs and
that's all it is it's nothing actually
stopped when you except for your
limiting beliefs and anytime you want to
make the next growth in yourself or in
your business it usually starts with
overcoming a limiting personal belief
that you have so you're not told to
start a business go out there follow
your passion get excited about it make
sure you had a ton of value to the
people who are going to be helping and
you'll build a social business I hope
that helps our team go out and get
started for those of you watching if you
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below and it also love to hear you
have to think if you have a question or
comment leave it underneath the video
and we'll
see you on the next episode
you